[Music]
breaking news tonight violence in the
heart of washington d.c
he started to lunge toward u.s capitol
police
the attack the victim and the suspect
also on this friday rethinking canada's
vaccine strategy
calls to immunize essential workers in
places where the virus is spreading
fast plus what are canadians who had at
least one vaccine dose
now allowed to do broadening the color
of autism
there is a lot of falling through the
gaps the lack of help for parents with
racialized children who are on the
spectrum
and oh dear
[Music]
a rude awakening for a sleeping student
on this school bus
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we enter another holiday weekend
still stuck in the pandemic there are
reminders not to gather with people
outside your household
the third wave fueled by new variants
means case counts keep rising in many
parts of this country
and younger people are getting sick
today quebec reported more than 1 300
new cases there the highest number since
january
the majority of the cases are believed
to be variants of concern
that province's public health institute
says more than 57 percent of tests
screened for variants over the past week
have turned out positive tighter
restrictions are in place
in quebec and in bc and they begin
province wide in ontario
tonight vaccinations are picking up but
not as fast as the variants are
spreading
and though the age-based strategy to
vaccinate older canadians first
has protected many of them thousands of
younger working age people who can't
stay home when there's a lockdown
are now getting sick that's led to calls
to rethink the vaccine strategy
travis danraj has our top story tonight
at this poultry processing facility in
lethbridge alberta
an outbreak last month led to more than
70 workers testing positive
in brampton ontario and amazon warehouse
saw 600 positive cases
weeks ago icu numbers in ontario are
hitting record highs
many in hospital essential workers you
need to make sure that it gets
where it um where it's going to have the
biggest impact
right now the government booking portal
only allows those 70 and over to make an
appointment
in a push to move faster some hospitals
have lowered that age
to begin immunizing people in high-risk
communities 50 and over
in ontario one of the biggest drivers
that we haven't addressed is the
occupational
household transmission chain and other
concrete living settings
more than 20 percent of community-based
deaths in ontario have occurred in just
10 percent of hot spots where covert 19
rates are highest
the areas include communities in windsor
hamilton ottawa and peel
and have higher rates of death
hospitalization and transmission
toronto is targeting specific area codes
identified as hot zones to ramp up
immunizations
using neighborhood data on infection
rates and case numbers as a guide
this is one of those areas toronto's
regent park
a diverse densely populated community
where many work in essential jobs and
don't have the privilege
of working from home during a lockdown
essential worker we cannot
stay work at home it is not possible but
we are less than 55 years old but we
everybody should be vaccinated in our
company four or five
people covered positive city councillor
joe cressy who was the chair of
toronto's board of health says expanding
the age range of those eligible in hot
spots
is only the first step getting people to
those clinics bringing those clinics
to people that's how we're going to
achieve herd immunity
it's why the city has launched a mobile
immunization campaign the province is
working on something similar but points
to vaccine supply as a problem
one more challenge to conquer during the
third wave travis stanrash global news
toronto
the federal government promises more
than a million vaccine doses are
expected to arrive in canada each week
in the coming months
at this point more than 5.9 million
doses have been administered across the
country
nearly 14 percent of the population has
received at least one dose
vaccines offer the path out of the
pandemic and today the american centers
for disease control issued travel
guidelines for americans who are fully
vaccinated
they can travel domestically and
internationally without having to show a
negative covid19 test or
quarantining unless the country they are
entering requires it the cdc still
recommends people wear masks and follow
public health precautions
here in canada there are no guidelines
yet for those who are vaccinated
abigail beeman reports we're waiting
until we can get back to the coffee
shops
these vancouver seniors are thrilled to
get their first vaccine but they know it
won't change
very much definitely won't relax about
it i'm kind of writing off 20 21.
you may breathe a sigh of relief after
that first shot but experts say
don't breathe it on someone else we're
still recommending that they wear a mask
they still practice good hand hygiene
and they still follow the public health
guidance because we don't have enough of
us vaccinated yet
and with coven 19 vaccines so new more
data is needed about protection
and spread we don't know a lot about how
much that protects other people
from getting covet from you or protects
you from transmitting covet
but the data on that is coming and it's
looking very positive
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention issued updated guidance again
friday for what fully vaccinated people
can do we state that
fully vaccinated people can resume
travel to low
at low risk to themselves while the cdc
still isn't recommending travel
experts say communication like that
helps boost vaccine confidence
i think if that messaging were to be
incorporated here a lot more people
would be happier to start getting their
vaccine so that we can
eventually return to some sense of
normalcy in canada
this country has seen no similar
guidance clear
transparent communication has been
lacking throughout this pandemic
just try and make sense of this recent
exchange on the topic in the house of
commons
planning on issuing any guidance on what
vaccinated canadians will or will not be
able to do
unlike the party opposite we do believe
in science and evidence including
the evidence that climate change is real
i will also remind the
opposite member that it is in fact work
with provinces and territories that
results in national guidance is she
planning on issuing with the on the
advice of her department any guidance
on what vaccinated can canadians can or
can't do
i am confident in is the safety of the
vaccines that have been approved by
health canada to save people's lives
one big question the world tries to work
out will we need to show proof of
vaccination to travel or to do certain
things
in ottawa discussions are ongoing with
g7 partners
and within cabinet about the question of
a vaccine passport
both internationally and sources say
more contentiously
within canada abigail beeman global news
ottawa health canada is advising
canadians not to use face masks that
contain something called graphene or a
biography
graphene is a novel nano material a
material made of
tiny particles that is reported to have
antiviral and antibacterial properties
health canada says inhaled graphene
particles could pose a health risk
it is doing a scientific assessment and
as a precaution
is asking companies to stop selling mass
that contain graphene
and for people to stop using them the
highly contagious p1 variant first
detected in brazil
that led to the closure of the whistler
black home ski resort in bc this week
appears to be spreading more rapidly in
that province than anywhere else in
canada
bc reported 379 cases of the p1 variant
on thursday
bc's top doctor says it's led to more
young people requiring
hospitalization the numbers of younger
people in
hospital are have gone up and that means
that the numbers younger people
are thankfully more likely to survive so
we know the length of stay
is longer and they more often are are
needing icu care so the percentage of
younger people who are in
icu has gone up
research has shown the p1 variant is up
to two and a half times more
transmissible and
though more research is needed there's
some evidence in brazil that it can
infect people who have been vaccinated
and possibly re-infect people who have
already recovered from cobit 19.
well hockey is on hold for the vancouver
canucks after five more players tested
positive for covid 19 placing more
strain on the nhl season schedule
seven players and one staff member are
now in covid 19 protocol and that number
could rise
the team may be allowed to practice
again on tuesday and the next three
games against the edmonton oilers and
the winnipeg jets have been postponed
under the nhl's guidelines players and
staff are required to take a covid test
every day in washington d.c another
capitol police officer has been killed
in an attack
in the heart of that city a car rammed
into a security barrier killing one
officer and injuring another
it happened just after 1 pm local time
on a day when no u.s politicians were
inside the capitol
congress is in recess right now jackson
prosco is near the scene tonight jackson
bring us up to speed on what we know
including about the suspect
and donna they're actually just towing
the car away from the scene right now as
the investigation continues
into what led up to this incident today
it plunged the capitol complex into
lockdown
as this vehicle rammed a security
checkpoint on the senate side
the driver is identified as a
25-year-old again motive is still
unclear at this point
two capitol police officers were struck
they opened fire and killed the suspect
but listen to how u.s capitol police
describe what sounds like it may have
been a premeditated attack
the suspect rammed his car
into two of our officers and then
hit the north barricade barrier
at such time the suspect exited the
vehicle
with a knife in hand our
officers then engaged that suspect
he did not respond to verbal commands
one police officer later died of his
injuries identified as william
billy evans an 18-year veteran of the
u.s capitol police
and understandably this has been an
incredibly traumatic year for u.s
capitol police they have lost four of
their officers
not only from today but in the wake of
the january sixth riots here on capitol
hill
donna there's still an ongoing debate
about long-term security measures here
at the capitol complex but the barriers
that were hit today
have been in place for decades those are
existing security measures
still an attack like this is incredibly
traumatizing both for those who work in
and around the capital complex and of
course the law enforcement officers who
are charged with guarding it
donna all right jackson proskow in
washington thanks
there's more turbulence tonight in the
canadian airline industry air canada's
plan to take over air transat
has been called off the companies
announced they've given up on the 190
million dollar deal first initiated two
years ago
mike armstrong explains what it means
and where it leaves air transat
the reason air canada tried to take over
air transit
may be the reason that's not happening
the goal was to grow
and control more of the market that's
something the european commission
wouldn't let happen air canada says it
tried to meet the conditions the ec
wanted to protect competition
but hit a limit in a statement the
company says quote
air canada has concluded that providing
additional onerous remedies
which may still not secure an ec
approval would significantly compromise
air canada's ability to compete
internationally now the canadian
government had already signed off on the
deal in announcing his approval in
february the transport minister said
the devastating impact of covet 19 on
the airline industry was a key
factor this would have created a much
larger
airline this airline industry analyst
says getting approval from the ec
likely would have meant giving up routes
to europe so as not to be too strong
competing with other carriers
that would have been one hurdle too many
for air canada
if they had to shrink in order to
complete this merger it probably didn't
make sense for our canada to do it
now to pull out of the deal air canada's
had to make some concessions
it has to pay air trans at a 12.5
million
termination payment it's also waiving a
10 million dollar fee
it would have been paid if air transact
were to find a new buyer
there may be one out there quebec media
mogul pierre carl pelado made his own
offer for the company in december and is
confirming it's still on the table
air transit said friday it's considering
pursuing those discussions
now the federal government is already
saying it's in talks with air transit
and
focused on protecting jobs there will
also be pressure on the quebec
government to support the company its
headquarters are in montreal but that
may be
slightly more delicate quebec's premier
has some ties to the company
about 30 years ago francois lego is one
of its
founders mike armstrong global news
montreal
the head of the minneapolis homicide
unit on the witness stand coming up
what he testified about derrick shoven
keeping his knee on george floyd's neck
there was some tense testimony at the
murder trial of former minneapolis
police officer derrick
chauvin today a high-ranking officer
called chauvin's use of force on george
floyd last may
totally unnecessary pulling him down to
the ground face down
and putting your knee on the neck for
that amount of that amount of time
it's just um uncalled for
um i saw no reason why
the officers felt they were in danger if
that's what they felt
and that's what they would have to feel
to be able to use that kind of force
so in your opinion should that restraint
have stopped once he was handcuffed
and prone on the ground absolutely
part of chauvin's defense is that he was
just doing what he was trained to do
the high profile murder trial resumes on
monday
there are signs tonight of a possible
return to talks on the iran nuclear deal
washington and tehran have agreed to
start
indirect talks with other major world
powers next week
this comes nearly three years after
president donald trump pulled the u.s
out of the deal president biden has said
rejoining the agreement is a priority
for his
administration negotiations are expected
to be difficult there are a number of
issues to be discussed including
sanctions
so far the u.s and iran are not expected
to have any direct
talks vaccinations and violence still
ahead the risks
facing frontline workers in war zones
terrible scenes in taiwan after an
express train with 500 people on board
derailed in a tunnel
some cars were ripped apart others
crumpled at least 51 people are dead
including the driver and more than 140
are injured
the train hit a truck that had rolled
onto the tracks from a work site above
some survivors escaped the wreck through
the windows or through the roof
the crash happened at the start of a
traditional long weekend holiday when
people head home to tend
to family graves aid workers in conflict
zones always do
dangerous work they provide critical
care while facing grave risks
just this week three women vaccinating
children against polio were shot and
killed in afghanistan
as countries around the world prepare to
roll out max kovid 19 vaccinations
crystal commansing looks at the risks to
the people doing it
the site of a coffin in a conflict zone
is not unusual but it doesn't make it
any easier to see
two separate shootings on tuesday led to
the deaths of three polio vaccination
workers
international laws protect health care
workers in conflict zones
still jason nickerson says the job can
be dangerous
if you're providing health care uh close
to front lines
that is inherently risky in a way that
working in a hospital in downtown ottawa
is is just not nickerson who is in
ottawa right now
recently spent time in the democratic
republic of congo
working to prevent the spread of ebola
covid19 vaccinations are a part of the
work being done by doctors without
borders
in lebanon local ceasefires are going to
be essential to enable
life-saving vaccinations to take place
britain's foreign secretary
successfully lobbied the u.n security
council to call on all nations
engaged in conflicts to pause for
humanitarian efforts
it's not that fear of covet 19
vaccinations would
increase the risk to workers but rather
an acknowledgment
of their critical roles
360 thousand doses of covid19 vaccine
recently arrived in yemen a country
plagued by a multi-sided civil war
that has raged for years if you see all
the misery on the ground if you see
people underneath on the ground
you can understand why we're doing this
work bhagwasetawan says risk management
is a critical part of his work with
oxfam in yemen
but he says people are the most
important part to him
you see how people are smiling you see
how people
appreciating the support given workers
regardless of their task or the logo on
their backs
say the need is too great to focus on
the risk
krystal gamansen global news london
autism across cultures next how race is
impacting the care of children
on the spectrum
you're watching global national
[Music]
the driver of this school bus didn't
even have time to react a deer
smashed through the front windshield
landing on a student who was hunched
over asleep
in the front seat it happened in
virginia the 15 year old in that seat
said afterwards he was stunned and
really confused but
he is okay and so is the deer which ran
off
when the bus driver opened the door
today is world autism awareness day
raising a child with autism can be
challenging and sometimes difficult
and as mike draulie explains adding
cultural differences
into the mix can make it even harder for
parents to find the support
their kids need for xavier jackson the
first hints of autism became apparent
at camp they said they can't handle him
i should come pick him up but it was
when he started kindergarten that his
mother
jane knew they needed help in his second
week he was suspended
because he had one of his educators
xavier was four when he was diagnosed
with autism and when she sought help she
says they found a system that
ignored multiculturalism eventually she
found a single session devoted to the
black community
there was also a punjabi session that i
attended because
they were talking about feelings of
shame
and i you know i said i can relate to
that
dr shivajan savapalan says we can't
ignore those cultural issues anymore
indeed language and culture were factors
in a 2017 study
that found black children are 19 percent
less likely than white children
to be diagnosed with autism before dr
sevapalan's autism clinic began
operating a mobile service to
marginalized communities
he would direct families to their
pediatricians
but then they would show up a year later
still with the same issues and i'm
realizing there is a lot of
you know falling through the gaps
foundations like camille proctor's the
color of autism aims to fix that
by doing outreach programs into
communities that are distrustful of
authority
and new to the idea autism doesn't see
race
initially the response was like why are
you trying to do something separate for
separate people this is segregation
and i'm like it's really not
proctor who is from detroit knows it's
an uncomfortable topic
especially in the current political
climate funding is also an issue as it's
always been with autism
but even if services aren't expanded in
the us and canada
education programs can be so there's so
many things that i think we all could do
to make this world better
i'm just trying to do my little work
mike lake global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen if you've got
children who can't wait for an easter
egg hunt we want to show you some
animals getting
in early on the fun meerkats and monkeys
at the london zoo had their own easter
egg hunt today each egg
filled with their favorite treats thanks
for watching
robin gill will be here at the anchor
desk this weekend and i will see you
again next week
take care of yourselves bye
[Music]
you